welcome I'm brandy house I am the
product manager for connected games at
unity and I'm joined today by three of
my friends and colleagues from Google
cloud and unity today we're going to
share a little bit more about what we
mean by connected games and how
matchmaking fits into that overall
problem space then Joseph will walk us
through an open match demo and where the
open source project is today then Caleb
will do a demonstration of custom match
functions and why we believe these will
open up new kinds of innovation and
matchmaking today and then Micah will
finish us off with an overview of the
Google cloud ecosystem for games so what
do we mean by connected games a few of
you may have seen me and Micah talk
about this before you know it could be
single-player games that are more
dynamic because they're connected
through cloud features and it could be
all the way through to MMO spaces you
know persistent games that are always
online and the way we think about this
space the further down the chart you go
the more cumulative the problem space is
so you have more technology and more
design problems that you have to solve
to be able to make those kinds of games
it just doesn't get easier it only gets
harder as you go down and what we've
been hearing from game does is that the
real-time multiplayer space and the and
the persistent world spaces are still
too hard and too expensive and too
difficult to build especially and really
the entire space is something that more
and more devs want to get to connected
to so today we're focused primarily on
the real-time multiplayer stack and from
what we've learned to make them
successful to get the latency Security
scale goals that your game needs the
tech stack really needs to be a
dedicated game server to Paulo G which
means that you have an entire stack from
the client runtime the networking code
all the way up to the game server
hosting and management and all of your
services and how you connect all of
those pieces together so we've been
collaborating with our Google Cloud
friends to create new services and new
opportunities for how we glue this
entire ecosystem together
and specifically today we want to talk
more about matchmaking we've heard from
many developers that this is actually
still one of the hardest unsolved
problems for games you know at its
fundamental level you really just need
to take players that are coming in to
play your game form you know quote
unquote good groups and then connect
them to a game server
it seems relatively simple but from what
we've seen that that definition of good
is actually quite subjective and it
changes game to game you know if it's a
more casual game you may care about
social graph distance if it's a
hyper-competitive game you may care more
and more about skill matching and so
being able to define what good means for
your game is a surprisingly hard problem
and there's not been a ton of innovation
in the space because so much of it is
still about how do I run a scalable
technology as opposed to how do I make
this a game design problem so from here
I'm going to hand off to Joseph who will
give an update about open match and the
progress of the open source
collaboration we've been working on
thank you brandy can we switch over to
the demo computer great alright so today
I'd like to briefly highlight some of
the recent things that we've been doing
an open match in the open source version
give you a little bit of a preview of
upcoming features so what you're looking
at right now is some metrics I have a
proof-of-concept matchmaker that's
running in kubernetes on Google cloud
I've seeded that with about 60,000
random players or so this is pretty
similar to the demo that we gave at
unite Berlin last year if any of you
have seen that it is on YouTube
I highly recommend you watch it this one
is a little bit different it's sending
four requests at a time instead of one
request at a time you can see it's
churning through about ten loops per
minute four requests per loop ten or
eleven loops so it's getting about forty
five matchmaker matchmaking loops going
per minute that's the bottom left-hand
the top right-hand is approximately how
many players are getting matched for a
minute sorry top left top right is
roughly how long each request that's
going up against open match is taking
you can see here they're taking a little
less than two seconds and the bottom
right sort of shows you how many of the
requests are actually finding a match
you can see there's a red line at the
bottom showing that like nothing is not
finding a match right now
so for requests at a time is not
particularly high by open match
standards what we really want is to be
able to get a lot of concurrent
processing done simultaneously so let me
bump this up from four to about 400 and
we're gonna see what happens to the
graphs hopefully everything should scale
out smoothly the idea here is we're
gonna slice up the parts of the player
pool that we're looking at into smaller
and smaller pieces and look for a match
within each one of those all at the same
time concurrently across lots of
processes in a kubernetes cluster so
some recent work that you
nnedi has finished and then contributed
the design back to the open source
project for making matchmaking functions
stay alive in the kubernetes cluster or
not spin down in between cycles so that
you get much lower latency matching is
really helping us bring this to life
right now so unfortunately my Griffin
instance is set to only refresh every 30
seconds so we're gonna have to be
slightly patient to see the big numbers
come up but hopefully as you can see
here like we're able to run a few
hundred sometimes this will get up over
a thousand matchmaking functions per
minute and that's able to put you know
tens of thousands of players through the
system per minute finding matches for
them this is kind of more about going
wide caleb is gonna talk a little bit
later about customizing the way that
you're looking for players and trying to
make each search that you're doing go
faster this is more about kicking off as
many searches as you can at a time so
the last thing I'd bring your attention
to in the bottom right you can see the
red line is starting to creep up now so
what that signifies is in certain parts
of the player population we've found
every available match there so when
we're looking in that part of the player
population for example if you think of
like a tiered game like a competitive
shooter like overwatch or something like
that this red in the bottom corner is
representing like your grandmasters or
your very low bronze players like we
have found all the potential matches for
that there's not enough players in the
pool to make anymore matches at that
part of the population so that's what
that's showing in the bottom can we go
back to the slides great so now I'm
gonna pass it over to Caleb and he's
going to talk about customizing those
matchmaking functions
Thank You Joseph
my name's Caleb I'm technical lead on
matchmaking at unity and we've been
working with Google on open match from
the beginning you know we want to solve
technically challenging problems for
game developers and make those solutions
generally available to game developers
at large in this case as Joseph was
showing some of these innovations are
coming in the form of services
infrastructure for matchmaking and so
what makes open match
here's clicker such a good fit for this
problem is that it's court has this
highly customizable component called
match functions so we've been talking a
little bit about match functions but
there's some examples on the repository
but not really a cohesive guide for how
to author one so over the next couple
minutes I wanted to try and demystify
match functions a little bit for you it
helps to start with this a little bit of
a simplified services model for how to
think about matchmaking services so on
the left you'll have your game client
with your players they'll broadcast to
the service a type of intent this could
be thought of as like a game mode some
quality of service data it's a regional
game service where your game servers are
hosted these will go through a front
door which will provide the secure data
from some type of persistent database
think like skill history inventory these
are things that you don't really want
the game client to be trusted to submit
at this point the service will package
those up and send those into the open
match front door no per match front door
is really good at indexing that data
making it highly available to through a
query API for the actual match functions
we'll get more on the match functions in
a second that's the blocks of these blue
blobs here what's nice is open match
takes care of kind of activating those
functions handling the cadence of those
functions kind of as Joseph was showing
we can achieve this high breadth of
distributed processing and so you only
have to worry about this little atomic
component in that the end results of a
match function is that it produces a
couple like proposals you can think of
them open match resolves the collision
of proposals so if players appear in
more than one proposal it is a
distributed system after all open match
will actually give you a the ability to
D collide those and out the backend come
matches
and so there's kind of two pieces to
this one is understanding the player
data and then the other side is the
actual authoring of the match functions
and so we'll start with player data
skill is kind of the super common
candidate for talking about this it's
something we all have a rudimentary
sense for and while we're not gonna talk
about skill specifically this is kind of
just an example of some distributed data
that you might have in your distribution
of data you would have in your
matchmaking system at any given time and
so from a match function perspective
we're talking about segmentation so
we're going to look at this when your
match function activates you're gonna
want to take like a slice of this data
and not like the full you know like the
middle one is super tall there's a lot
of players in there so you would even
take a smaller slice of that and the
match function is mostly gonna focus on
taking those 10 200 you know 10 200
players or so if you put those together
arguably that would be possibly a close
match if it's a pretty comprehensive
skill system and so if we move a little
further back we can start to identify
kind of the core set of player data
you're gonna need to be worried about
for like a basic matchmaking experience
and so on the top right here we have
skill blow that is wait time which is
kind of an interesting one from a match
function perspective for this particular
metric you might want to have a match
function for example that is going to
specifically focus on the right side of
this chart find players that have been
waiting a long time for matches and then
specifically target those players with
proposals that have a higher urgency or
priority to provide those back to open
match open match provides this evaluator
concept that allows you to use that
priority to prefer those matches over
other matches that players might be
appearing in so this helps solve for I
don't have a deterministic way to
understand why players aren't getting
matches quickly now if you've worked in
a dedicated game server architecture on
the top left you'll recognize some of
these numbers so these are going to be
round-trip times to regional data
centers where your game servers can be
ran this is super important for
matchmaking because you want to take
these players that have an actual like
location on earth they
have that last mile they have to be
concerned about and so you can find that
common node that they're all gonna
connect to to get that tight low latency
gameplay that you want in your game so
for a match function I could say give me
players that have less than 120
millisecond ping to us West's with this
slice of skill with an average wait time
and if that produced you know 8 or 80
matches as proposals those would
possibly be like basic ideal matches but
of course this and this doesn't even
scratch the surface you have tens
hundreds thousands of data points that
you care about when you're doing your
matchmaking because good really does
depend on what you're trying to do with
your game whether it's a social
experience or a super competitive
experience so level reputation attached
inventory one of my personal favorites
is current win streak so if I go into a
game I've won nine games I'm gonna go
against a set of players possibly who
have also won nine games in a row and so
that's really what open match is trying
to solve is taking away some of the
technical difficulties of running a
matchmaking service and provide that
sandbox for creating a powerful custom
way to bring your players together
that's not talked about actually writing
match functions this is by no means like
a prescriptive way to do this if you
first get started though I have a
suspicion they'll mostly look in this
form so step 0 is to describe your data
make your data and design it anything
that you can preempt as an index going
into open match that's definitely going
to be preferable to trying to build that
on run time out of segmentations that
you've been creating then once you're in
the actual function you've been
activated you want to build and run this
query when you get back your tickets
you'll want to do some type of
optimization most algorithms between two
and three it's kind of whatever you'd
like to do a lot of algorithms will have
you like build hash maps and do
normalization on the pool that you're
actually working with so you can kind of
create that richer algorithm 3 put the
players together an example that I'm
going to show
I just use a bucket cessation mechanism
where if the ticket fits into a bucket
you go in the bucket and if there's not
room in the bucket you go in the next
bucket and so it seems kind of
rudimentary but it actually choose a
pretty interesting result and the last
thing you can do inside of your match
function is you have an opportunity to
put a little extra data in there so if
the players asked or have preferences
for the map they're going to be on now
might be a time that you would want to
like roll a die and actually assign what
map they're going to play on so the
server when it gets that information
it's already configured and so with this
completely bespoke approach it really
opens a lot of options that are
sometimes difficult to achieve with a
configuration or rules based matchmaker
for instance I mentioned well like dye
combining your data or making decisions
based on the population you're working
with inside of that query so for example
I were here for skill but the confidence
of that skill isn't very good for the
players I got back it's a new game I
shipped a new mode I don't know how good
they are at that point I could
technically switch to relying on another
metric to try and figure out whether or
not those players should play together
and I can do that inside of the same
match function this is also a good
opportunity to inject something like a
social graph so if you have your own
social graph you could make a highly
performant off box call has to be pretty
quick we could try and resolve
interesting connections that you can
form out the population you're working
with there we go all right so if we can
switch over to the demo laptop so
showing code on stage is always an
interesting challenge I do my best not
to like show just a huge mess of
spaghetti that's hard to grok so I
apologize if some of these functions
seem very helper e but I think they kind
of highlight the life cycle of what a
function might look like and so when
you're writing your match function
you'll likely be working in something
like a harness open match we're working
on providing a whole suite of harnesses
for different languages you're working
with in this case a lot of folks who use
unity no C sharp and net so we have a
harness we're working with dotnet
in this case it's this configurable
match function and as you can see it has
this execute function this is your
entrance to your match function we will
receive a kind of context object from
open match this will contain some
interesting information about how I was
activated some filters that the backend
created I have a query interface for
accessing my ticket data and executing
those queries on those index as I
mentioned and then we have this custom
piece of configuration that I've know
submitted through a dev dashboard in the
backend and so this will mostly follow
what we I was showing you a second ago
we're going to submit this query as I
said the context contains these filters
that I've made on the back end I will
collect my tickets and then these two
functions which are those he'll
pre-function cells talking about place
tickets on teams is just going to take a
bucket if you fit you go in the bucket
and then I'm going to basically expand a
major make a whole bunch of buckets for
the the second one here place teams on
proposals my match function is actually
configurable and that's what this is up
here so depending on the number of teams
I want in this game it will then take as
many buckets as I need and collapse
those into a proposal so if I need 20
it'll take 20 buckets to put them
together now opportunity for
customization before I put a ticket on a
team there's an interesting gameplay
design that I want to introduce my game
is very creative collaborative game I
like it when players have an opportunity
to interact with people that they like
interacting with but in this particular
case it's a very collaborative
environment so I also want them to
identify folks that they might not want
to keep playing with from session to
session and so into my party concept
I've introduced this idea of a list of
other parties that I'd like to not
continue matchmaking with so in other
words I was playing I had a great group
going we were all talking and it's not
that someone wasn't collaborating they
just weren't talking so I want to play
with more people who like talking so
what I've done here is I've introduced a
hash map of those party IDs and I simply
D collide for these two here am I
avoided so does the party team I'm
trying to matchmake into do they have
players that don't wanna play
me and do I avoid them so these will be
are there parties inside that team that
I have elected not to want to play with
and then we will take note of some
interesting metrics when we actually run
this function and just to clarify this
concept isn't quite like reputation I'm
not identifying people in my community
who are going to quote bad or poisonous
this is kind of just a self elected
mechanism that your players can use to
avoid players that they just don't want
to play with and so because this is just
a function and I'm using this I'm
writing this right next to my own game
logic I can write unit tests for this I
can mock my data layer I can verify that
when I change something I don't regress
and so this is a very powerful way to
test your like matchmaking logic
so here I've mocked my ticket interface
with some memory data I have this
function that I'm calling that just
generates traffic in this case I'm
generating 10,000 tickets of randomly
one to four players on each ticket now
in addition to that I'm also generating
one to ten random other parties that
each ticket is trying to avoid and so
there's a whole bunch of players self
electing into this interesting game
mechanic now here's that custom config I
mentioned in this case I'm having 16 to
20 players on a team and there are four
teams per match and with this I can
actually run this function and we can
see how quickly execute and how it does
everyone can see that okay great so as
you can see there were 20,000 players
that were currently matchmaking in this
pool now I have a filter here for us
West good ping so in other words I'm
only gonna get players that are near my
us West data center 4,000 tickets about
technically qualified it looks like only
one ticket wasn't able to fit into a
given match and I actually was able to
avoid eight matchups that if I hadn't
done anything those players would have
been stuck playing with players they
didn't want to play with again well this
doesn't seem like a high number this
compounds over the course of your your
game cycle if I'm able to avoid eight
every single loop or 16 every single
loop we're talking about thousands of
improved
matches that day so the end results of
this was 400 proposals which are
potential matches to open match which is
quite a few and this only took 148
milliseconds to run now there are some
optimizations that I could make around
my bucketing it's pretty not a
particularly advanced bucketing system
but as long as you you know keep your
performance between here and like a
second or so you're looking at a pretty
quick matchmaking turnover especially
once you get distributed so that seemed
to the code if I get back to the demo
slides awesome and so multiplayer
matchmaking built on open match we've
been working on this handy service that
helps bring dedicated game server
developments and scaling but with that
super powerful and accessible experience
you've come to expect from unity we've
developed this new multiplayer
matchmaking system so it fully
integrates with multi plays phenomenal
world scaling technology it's still open
match at the core so you still get
access to the same customizable
components like custom match functions
and custom configuration alongside that
tooling and lifecycle management
experience that will be coming to the
unity ecosystem of course it's a hosted
service that means don't worry about
operations scaling monitoring and
because it's a service it's also engine
agnostic so no matter where you're
coming from whether it's unity or
something else you can get started with
multiplayer right away
great with that I will let Micah talk
more about the cloud gaming ecosystem
with GCP
Thank You Caleb that was an awesome demo
it's been fun watching the evolution of
open match over the past year in Google
cloud we really believe strongly in
being engine agnostic platform agnostic
so part of our vision for for gaming is
to make sure that you can get your
service is running and reach as many
players as possible so you may have seen
the announcement for stadia yesterday
which works really well with Google
cloud but we're not only powering stadia
we can power any games we're really
ready to scale up whatever workloads are
thrown at us if it's stadia we're on the
same private network as those stadia
instances which is great because you can
have predictably low latency really
great value with no internet egress and
great data security because that data
never gets onto the internet but having
that infrastructure hosted on Google
cloud also enables you to power the
other platforms that you're targeting
for your game we also have solutions
around data and analytics figuring out
player insights like which players are
going to pay or not pay in the next
seven days which players are going to
leave your game in the next seven days
lots of great opportunities to figure
out how to optimize your your game and
make a better experience we have a great
relationship with unity and we really
appreciate our efforts together and our
friends at multi play have done some
really amazing work over the past 20
years we're excited to see what they can
do next
so I thank you very much for joining us
I'm waiting for my slide to advance
sorry there we go if you want to get
involved in our community please jump
into open match it's an open source
community it's easy to get involved
maybe you just want to ask some
questions
join the slack channel there's an email
list if you're just kind of poking
around if you want to be a contributor
we are more than welcome to join in and
grab some issues we're excited to see
what the community wants to do with this
project and finally a part of our vision
for Google in general is to connect to
create connect and scale your games and
so we're bringing the best of Google
together
and this is something you're gonna see a
lot more from us coming forward thank
you
[Applause]